Juillet 1969 dix jours avant le premier homme
sur moi
l'autorisation se heurte à des
problèmes techniques le chef de la CIA décide d'
envoyer un agent spécial à Londres pour trouver
Stanley Kubrick je vais me renverser et
lui demander de filmer secrètement un faux
alunissage  au cas où le vrai échouerait, ce
héros est Tom Kidman, aucun mec sûr, donnez-moi
son courtois, ouvert d'esprit et diplomate.
Kidman ne trouvera jamais Kubrick, il trouve
Johnny à la place, nous avons une proposition pour
m.  Kubrick oh c'est une
somme d'argent considérable dans ce projet
Je ne ressemble en rien à Stanley Kubrick pourquoi
ne puis-je pas être Hitchcock non seulement Stanley
Kubrick un projet de film crédible et important
nous avons décidé qu'il n'y avait qu'un seul homme au
monde qui pouvait réussir ceci et cet
homme  c'est le mec de Johnny
le truc je pense que t'es un message dessus
t'es désorganisé t'es inefficace
t'es pas capable de donner une touche de classe
et surtout il faut qu'on s'en sorte
il casse ça s'emmerde ok
hé là
aucun ne me fait vibrer et toi aussi [ __ ] de
sauce j'ai un homme de téléphone qui atterrit sur le
[ __ ] maintenant
mr.  Kidman ici sait aussi si vous serez
intéressant de faire un film pour son
entreprise ce matin est beaucoup trop gris
sa petite grenouille sur terre du tout
bien sûr c'est un réalisateur
ce qui est toujours de la merde
il le fout totalement l'
acide est la meilleure chose  pour les maux de tête
quoi